and there is no sign of a solution to
Washington's Christmas budget standoff
that threatens to shut down much of the
government president Trump is standing
firm but he doesn't seem to have enough
Republican standing with him the White
House and Congress have until midnight
on Friday to agree on funding for the
president's proposed border wall which
Democrats oppose Republican lawmakers
say they're in the dark about a plan to
avoid a weekend shutdown major Garrett
is at the White House a major what is
the administration's strategy well look
Washington knows that government
shutdowns even partial ones are
inefficient costly and politically
hazardous but Washington's heading
toward one because the President
President Trump doesn't appear to have a
strategy to avert one or if he does he
hasn't shared it with congressional
Republican leaders what does the
president want five billion dollars to
build a border wall on the us-mexico
border or at least part of it but
there's not enough votes in the House
Republican caucus to do that that
diminishes the president's leverage he
can't get it passed in the
republican-led House or Senate aides
here have suggested the president a
stopgap short-term spending bill into
January but that would be under new
house Democratic management the
negotiations would be even tougher
the president's leverage diminished so
he wants to stand firm but without the
votes he doesn't have many plausible
political or strategic alternatives
Democrats have offered 1.3 billion
dollars of border security that doesn't
include very much for the wall accepting
that would be a defeat the president
would rather not take so here we sit
waiting for the president to see if he
can find a way to victory or recalibrate
or read ascribe defeat so major the
president has an acting chief of staff
Mick Mulvaney who was once a
conservative member of Congress used to
play footsie with the idea of shutdowns
when he was there so what's his role
here in this drama well he is leaving
the talks to try to avert a government
shutdown but also prepare the government
in case there is one and partial
government funding expires midnight
Friday
he's also shadowing chief of staff John
Kelly why in preparation to become the
full chief of staff July 2nd John
January 2nd scuse me John Thank You
major